hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the Leipzig Olympiad of
1960 it is a game between Grand Master
Jonathan Penrose and the world champion
Michael tal this tournament was played
in November until uh had his world Chase
championship match against Mikhail
between in March of 1960 uh so the atal
already world champion here and for
those who are wondering uh is Jonathan
Penrose in any way related to Sir Roger
Penrose yes that is definitely the case
uh Jonathan is his brother and we've uh
We've covered a game Jonathan played in
1950 I believe I made a video on it two
years ago as Jonathan died in 2021 so if
you haven't seen that game do check it
out I will put a link to it in the
description below and also uh uh you
know regarding the photo in the
thumbnail I wanted to show you the game
between tal and Fisher from the 1960
chess Olympia but I've already shown
that game and if you haven't seen it do
check it out it's quite a beautiful game
it's a really uh in those days it was
called modern day brilliant scene will
also be in the description below so
maybe check out those two videos before
watching this one or you know after this
one it will greatly improve your vast
knowledge now getting back to this game
uh tal never wanted to play this game
it's a final round and the day after
this game was supposed to be played uh
was Tal's birthday and he wanted to be a
free he wanted to have a day off about
the team captain said that tal had the
plane and the thought said that if he's
forced to play that he will lose on
purpose now of course no one thought
that that would actually happen because
tal was undefeated in this tournament he
was the world champion and I mean I mean
when you're at that level you just don't
lose on purpose because it's your
birthday tomorrow I mean okay maybe you
want to go out celebrating a bit early
and that definitely does sound like
something tal would do it just you don't
think that so let's check out the game
and you guys tell me what what actually
happened here so Jonathan has the white
pieces and he opens with Fontana E4 and
of course if you play D4 again style in
those days you will see this Knight to
F6 C4 E6 Knights the C3 and C5 toggles
for the benoni defense we have Fanta D5
he captures and d5c captures and pawn to
D6 with Ponte E4 uh and now upon the G6
preparing the film get to the dark
Square bishop and nowadays the F4 is the
and most popular way to play this also
Knight to F3 is fine uh but uh Bishop to
D3 is the third most popular option and
it's uh still fine if you played today
in 2023 Bishop to G7 with Knight G2 E2
and now both players just Castle so
castles castles we have A6 and now Pawn
to A4 of course stopping B5 with Queen
to C7 vital uh now preparing Pawn to C4
and then you will want to bring this
Knight over to C5 those are just some
standard um uh benoni uh Maneuvers with
H3 Knight beta D7 and now Ponte F4 tile
place Rook the E8 puts more pressure on
the E4 pawn and Knight the G3 adds
another Defender to the third upon and
now tal goes for it pawn to C4 attacks
the bishop Bishop to C2 and now Knight
the C5 now the Knight is excellently
placed here at some point the Knight
might come to B3 tonight might come to
D3 uh we have Queen to F3 you also need
to defend that E4 Pawn uh so Queen to F3
and now uh there are a couple of games
that reach this position in those days
and also maybe not a bad way to continue
would be something like Rook to B8 to
prepare B5 and if white stops this with
A5 you can still play Rook to B Pawn to
B5 and it's a very interesting position
for example captures capture snap on to
F5 and um the game continues but tal
decided to play Knight after D7 and it
is now as of move 15 that this position
has never been reached again
so uh Jonathan goes for Bishop to E3 uh
and now Tao plays Pawn to B5 and this is
uh uh the the the the the first
sub-optimal move tile place in this game
now B5 is the movie you want to play you
just want to prepare it a little bit
first and since the queen moved away
from the defense of the D3 Square uh
Knights the D3 does seem like uh like uh
an idea to explore a point is that now
after let's say captures captures and
rotate to D1 you want to win the pawn
talk can defend it and now after let's
say Bishop F2 to add another attacker to
the pawn now you can go uh for a counter
attack with Pawn to B5 and upon the B5
is uh very very strong here now because
it's very hard for white to find the
move you're gonna have to play some like
real captures on D3 then B captures an
A4 and it's a complete mess of a
position the problem with trading Queens
here is that after captures and captures
black has this incredibly strong Pawn to
B4 move and now after the Knight moves
in you have to really be careful it's an
id1 A5 can be played now Bishop there A6
is a huge threat and after Rook D1 uh
still Bishop to A6 attacks The Rook
let's say Rook D2 and now Rook 8 to C8
and this definitely looks like a
position Tower would thrive in I mean
you have the the control of the C file
you have the fully operational Bishop
pair uh it's easy for the knights to get
into the game I mean
uh this is definitely a position tile
would uh enjoy playing and he would
obliterate anyone here but he rushed it
with Pawn to B5 and this is where I I
almost believe uh talwin he said that he
would lose on purpose not that he wanted
to lose would B5 he just didn't put in
that extra effort that he well almost
always puts in so a captures on B5 he
plays Rook to B8 and now Queen to F2 uh
putting putting pressure on the Knight
Here and Now E5 will be somewhat of of a
problem a capture some B5 and now Pawn
to E5 trying to get uh well uh a very
strong Center uh in the least the E6
will be an idea in the future if you
capture then the Knight will no longer
be defended so tall does capture D
captures an E5 as for the moment the
Knight is defended twice but now comes
spawn to F5 and this is something that I
uh often say about tal when I uh cover
his games where he plays against a very
strong attack attackers that sometimes
tal enjoys the attack so much that it's
almost as if he wishes for the attack to
succeed he you know he respects the
attack even more than his own result in
the game what one could say so here the
only way for thought to defend is to go
back Rook Rook to f8 but it's not a move
a very characteristic of of Tal's style
but I will show it because it's even
with Rook the field which is the
absolute strongest move recommended by
the engine the defense is uh I mean you
do not you you can't see this for
example Ponte F6 by white and now you
have to capture the problem with going
back let's say Bishop they cheat is that
D6 is coming and now black is just
completely busted if Queen captures on
D6 look at this Knight the F5 now you
can't capture the the Knight because of
Queen G3 check you can't capture the
pawn because the queen hangs and if you
play Queen captures on F6 then comes
Knight to D5 attacks attacks the queen
and you're out of moves here you have to
give up the queen if you play Queen to
E6 then just Knight d37 check and now
the king is aramo so that's you're gonna
have to give up your your queen either
way so that's why after this uh um uh
Point F6 move you can't really afford
yourself the luxury of going back you're
gonna have to capture here Bishop
captures on F6 but now Bishop captures
and C5 and everything gets traded off
Queen captures and C5 Queen captures
Knight captures now Rook captures on F6
and the white is just much much better
here you are you are down a piece with
black and uh well it's uh not not very
not very pleasant you are you have you
do have two pawns for the piece uh it's
just not very very believable and uh
that is if black plays the absolute best
defense dab is Rook to f8 but here top
played Bishop to B7 and now comes Rook a
to D1 now this is a uh a slight misplay
by uh by Jonathan the problem is uh here
after this bishop to B7 move you can
just win on the spot with f characters
on G6 but it's a weird because you know
that you're not gonna be capturing
anything look at this F captures and G6
now Queen to F7 is nothing because you
just put the King on h8 the move that
both of them obviously missed is Bishop
captures on G6 and now after H captors
Queen to F7 check King the h8 and now
Queen captures on G6 and now you have
all sorts of problems like Rook coming
to 5 to H5 so you have to prevent this
let's say Rook to f8 but now Knight
captures on B5 attacks the black queen
and you can feel that uh this is not
going the way you plant Queen to the
eight Knights the D6 now going for
Knight to F7 check and now after Bishop
captures on D5 Guardian F7 you will play
Knight G to F5 and there's just no
surviving this for black
uh so really a really a hard position uh
but yeah he missed it he played Rook 8
to D1 instead and now tal has a new
lease on life he plays Bishop to e A8
which is also a sub-optimal move you
have to play Pawn to E4 uh but this is a
complete mess uh of a game the top lead
Bishop to A8 now the B5 Pawn is defended
but not Knight seat to E4 with knights
the A4 by tal and now Bishop captures an
A4 again interestingly F captures and G6
is winning but it's it's like both of
them are missing this the point now is
that after Caprice and captures and
queen to F7 check King to h8 there's
this incredible Knight to H5 just
threatening Checkmate and after you
capture it now Knight to G5 with the
idea of Queen captures on H5 followed by
Queen captures on H7 it's like when when
tal is playing either he's attacking or
he is getting brutalized with some sort
of a crazy attack like this and now
let's say Pony form you have to block
the the bishop here doesn't really
matter Ponte DC 6 and after the queen
moves now I play Queen captures on H5
and you either get checkmated or you
play H6 but then Knight to F7 check for
example will win the queen this is only
one of the winning lines all of them are
winning and it's weird that both of them
are missing F captures on G6 but what
are you gonna do uh best shop captures
on A4 was played B captures on A4 and
not F captures on G6 with f captures on
G6 now Queen to F7 with check King to h8
and not Knight the C5 and this is a
beautiful move uh the Knight cannot
capture because the queen on C7 hangs so
now tal is tal of course he will find a
way to complicate he plays Queen to A7
now if the Knight moves top can play
Queen captures on E3 with check and
that's a big problem for him uh for uh
Jonathan but it can all be solved with a
simple King to H2 however Queen captures
on D7 is played he grabs the piece and
now tall trades Queen captures with
Knight captures on D7 and now Rook
captures on B2 now towels down a piece
but he does have the past C pawn and the
past a pawn so Knights to B6 going after
those pawns and tal has to decide which
one to give up he could also play Rook
to B4 but then your Rook is just very
inactive and you don't want to play that
then D6 is coming D7 it it looks very
passive so instead after Knight the B6
Rook the B3 was played by tal attacking
the bishop here but now just Knight
captures and C4 eliminates the pawn and
defends the bishop here we have rooked
the d8 now attacking the pass d-pawn and
pawn to D6 it's nicely defended here
Rook to C3 goes after the Knight and now
just to Rook the C1 defending the Knight
we have Rook captures on C1 Rook
captures on C1 and now Bishop to D5
uh Knight the B6 now attacks the bishop
and the bishop to B3 defends the pawn
and nicely controls the uh the Knight on
B6 Knight to E4 and here Ponte H6
stopping Knight to G5 because the Knight
really wants to come to G5 and to F7 uh
we have Pawn to D7 by Jonathan and here
Tao really is out of moves because the
the if you start advancing the pawn
let's say Pawn to A3 then Rook the uh
sorry Rook to see it can be played and
there's nothing uh you can play here you
can't capture because the queen comes
into the game and if you play Rook to G8
then just The Rook captures Bishop
captures and now the eighth queen and
that's it if Pawn to A2 can just play uh
Queen to A8 and the pawn will never
promote so top figure is a different
plan of course you cannot defend with
Bishop to F6 then I discovering that so
he plays Bishop to f8 Now The Rook will
be defended with Bishop to E7 once the
the white Rook lands on C8 so Rook the
C8 by Jonathan and now tal just plays of
the E7 but even though it seems like Tao
has now defended and that his a pawn is
winning feel free to pause the video and
win the game for Jonathan uh while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
well uh incredible idea and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is of course Bishop to C5 this is what
Jonathan played uh and now there really
isn't anything more fertile uh to to try
here if you capture ninja through
captures rook and if Bishop to H4 which
was played in the game uh Jonathan just
played Pawn to G3 and he was in this
position and move 39 that world champion
mikaltal resigned to the game as there
is nothing more to be done here so Tara
played a brilliant tournament he did not
lose a single game but this game that he
promised that he will lose if they force
him to play it uh he did lose but as
you've seen in the game it's not uh for
for lack of trying Jonathan really
played a spectacular game tal had a few
sub-optimal moves but then again you
have to I really really do well to uh to
exploit those so here you resign because
the bishop has no squares
um of course you're going to lose the
bishop and then you don't really even
care about the distribute you just want
to get rid of the Bishops you can play
Rook capture Sunny 8 and there is no
counter play here there is no Move that
dog can make here to even try and make
something of this game so it's a really
uh just a terrible terrible position uh
so yeah really really nicely done by by
Jonathan Penrose like I said the only uh
lost uh tall suffered in this in in this
tournament now I haven't shown you the
Fisher game because I've already Sean
Fischer versus style for those of you
who haven't seen it first link in the
description below and now regarding the
photo in the thumbnail that you guys are
are interested in uh here you can see a
couple of gentlemen here they have all
the way on the far far left is mikhail's
old old Mentor Alexander koblenz then
you you have tal here really how uh you
know laughing it out then Lombardi next
to him and then uh Fisher all the way to
the right I don't know who the woman in
the photo is if anyone knows do share in
the comments so we can all learn but
basically uh Fisher said the thought
that he was
that he was studying palmistry lately I
guess that's the the art of reading
someone's future from their palm and he
Fisher told tal that he will lose his
world's championship title to a young
American uh to uh and that tal turned
over to Lombardi and he said
congratulations bill as he was also a
young American so he he said no no way
Bob you're not becoming world champion
and they were all having a good time
having a laugh
um so you know I I it looks like they're
having the the best of times so I I'm
very happy that at this moment took
place it's it's probably not a photo
from that exact moment but in in my mind
it always will be uh so yeah that's the
game I hope you guys enjoyed it we'll
we'll probably cover all the other games
that I'll play the in the this
tournament and I should definitely cover
the entire tournament and all of the
cool games that were played because it
is a wonderful uh tournament so uh I
will make a playlist uh and uh you know
uh from time to time I will come back to
this tournament and cover it but until
then you know we'll just enjoy whatever
else is happening in the Chess World uh
so yeah and that's the game I really
hope you guys enjoyed it uh I would like
to thank David Kimura the
golfsoftware.com uh Paul hinemun Gary
Shaw and revision reptiles YouTube for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the Chess
World so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day